The next step now, is to have
a way to turn off the recording
once you've started recording something.
For that, we will need, you guessed it.
Our stop recording button.
We'll also need an IP-action
from the stop recording button
to the view controller code.
Make sure you are on the assistant
view with the storyboard and
the view controller files open.
Control drag from this button
into the view controller and
select the option to
create an IB action.
Let's name this IB action
stopped recording.
In this action, let's add a line to
print out when this button was pressed
by adding the following code.
We should be able to run
the pitch perfect app now.
And if we press the stop
recording button,
we'll see our caveman debugging
output in the Xcode console.
Let's give it a try.
We're almost there.
The next step is to add the constraints
to our new label and button and
then to wire up some IBoutlets so
that the Recording and
Stop Recording buttons are not
both enabled at the same time.